اكتب الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان لي
بلاده حقا مشروعا في المناطق التي حددتها
خارج حدودها من اجل حمايه امنها وشدد
الرئيس التركي على انه ليس بامكانه احد
منع انقره من استخدام هذا الحق وقال
اردوغان اين قوات بلاده استطاعت تحديدا
نحوي اربعمائه وثمانين ممن وصفهم
بالارهابيين في العمليه العسكريه الجاريه
في العراق وسوريا
تم تحيده 4080 ارهابيا في عمليات المخلب
القفل وفي سوريا لدينا شهداء ونحن ندعو
لهم بالرحمه لعائلاتهم بالسلوان ستكون
الخساره عاقبه كل من ينظر شذرا لتركيا
لدينا كل الحق المشروعي في تامين امننا في
المناطق الواقعه داخل حدودنا وخارجها ولا
يسع احد ان يقفه استخدامه هذا الحق
[موسيقى]
تركيا
الشمالي سوريا والعراق
وقالت ان جنديه تركيا قتل متاثرا باصابته
برصاص حزب العمال الكردستاني في العمليات
العسكريه الجاريه الشماليه العراق العراق
ونشرت وزاره الدفاع التركيه في حسابها على
تويتر مشاهده القصص المدفعيه الذي استهدفت
الكلب المواقع